بسرعه البرق وعلى رمال السعوديه تجري
سباقات السرعه راليل للمره الرابعه في
السعوديه بعد نسخ ثلاث الماضيه لذكر
السعوديه ياتي ضمن رزنامه الفعاليات
والاحداث العالميه التي تستضيفها المملكه
في مدينه ينبع هذا العام والممثله بعده
مراحل النسخه الحاليه هي الخامسه
والاربعون
والذي بدا بين باريس ذكر في عام 1979
لتستضيفه عده دول بعد ذلك تتنافس في
الرالي ثلاث فئات هي فئه الدراجات وفئات
السيارات وفئه الشاحنات وتحصل في هذا
الرالي منافساتهم طاحنه بين مصنعي
السيارات
واه يستغلون هذا الرالي لاظهار متانه
سياراتهم وايضا كحق الاختبار لها لغرض
تعديلها للافضل المزيد مع علاء
في العالم والاكثر متعه واثاره نظرا للطرق
المستخدمه فيه ونوعيه المركبات والدراجات
الداخليه في المسابقات السباق هو من
الانشطه الرياضيه القليله عالميا التي
تفتح ابوابها للمحترفين والهواه ليس ذلك
فحصت بل يشكل الهواتف نحو 80% من
المتسابقين الرالي الشهير احد اطول
اراليات واكثرها استمراريه على مدى الايام
المتواصله حيث يستمر لنحو 14 يوما يخوض
فيه المتسابقون منافساتهم بطرق متعدده
منها الرملي والطيلي والصخري كذلك الجبليه
داكار بدا في اوله كسباق يمر بين العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس والعاصمه السنغاليه دبكه
لكنه تغير مع الايام واصبح يقام في مناطق
مختلفه حيث اقيم سابقا بين الارجنتين
وتشيلي ومره بدول عربيه مثل الجزائر وتونس
وايضا مصر ليصل الى تنظيمه الكلي الى
السعوديه بدءا من عام 2020 واستمرارا حتى
2030 في شراكه تاريخيه مع السباق الابرز
[موسيقى]
على كل من حاجه صباح العربيه محمد الدماس
في اول اطلاله محمد يسعد صباحك معانا صباح
العربيه اول اطلاله لك منورنا اهلا بك من
حائل
اهلا وسهلا بكم
صباح جميل لكن بروده عاليه مع منافسه
كبيره مع رياضه
من اشهر الاثاره في العالم لرياضه
المحركات والسيارات كما هو معروف الان
النسخه الرابعه هنا في السعوديه والتي
ستمتد الى ما يقارب 15 يوم
وبمسافه ربما تكون همم او ما يقارب 5,000
كيلو متر ابتداء او ستبتدي المرحله الاولى
من ينبع ومرورا بالربع الخالي ثم الرياض
وانتهاء
بالشرقيه همم الدمام
ويعني كما شاهدت الان من المنافسات او من
خلال اللقطات التي شاهدتموها على همم
الشاشه هناك منافسه كبيره يعني صراحه هذا
الراديو من اصعب واا يعني امتع فيها صعوبه
لكن هناك متعه في هذه الرياضه عندما شاهد
الكثير من المتسابقين الذي يعود مبتسم
والذي يعود ربما يكون عليها انهاك وتعب
كذلك هناك كانت صراحه بدايه في مدينه ينبع
وكان استقبال جميل من هذه ينبع من اهازيج
السمسميه التي تراث المدينه وكذلك التراث
البلدي بدا طبعا المنافسات من بدايه
المرحله الاولى او المرحله التمهيديه
وبعدها انطلقت المرحله الاولى من ينبع الى
العلا ثم بدات المرحله الثانيه من العلا
الى حائل وستبقى هنا المرحله الرابعه التي
ستكون على شكل دائري على مدينه حائل ومن
بعدها تتواصل المرحله الخامسه الى
الدوادمي وهي تتكون الى 14 مرحله
طيب محمد النسخه الخامسه والاربعين من
رامي داكار ما الذي يميزها هذه السنه عن
ان نسخ الثلاثه السابقه
صراحه همم كان هناك في بدايه الانطلاقه في
ينبع رجل فرنسي اسمه جاكي هذا الرجل شارك
حدود 40 نسخه الذكر من خلال يعني عندما
تحدث الكثير هناك ان هذه النسخه التي تقام
في السعوديه من اجمل النسخه التي
ذكر خاصه وهو متسابق عالمي ومعروف الان
همم 40 عام ربما يكون انا اعتزل نهائيا
وذكر انه هنا تضاريس جميله جدا تعطي
الحماس والقوه والنديه بالبارحه كانت هناك
يعني صعوبه من همم
من العلا الى هنا حائل كان صعوبه كبيره
وبالغه امطار على تضاريس صعبه على اشياء
كثيره لكن كثير من المتسابقين وجدوا متعه
في هذه الشيء الجميل في ذلك رغم ان هناك
يعني متنافسين عالمين
ومشاركين ذو خبره عالميه في هذه الرياضه
الى هناك الان منافسه كبيره بين السعوديه
من السعوديه وقطر السعوديه يزيد الراجحي
والقطري ناصر العطيه الذي تصدر المرحله
والذي ياتي بعد يزيد الراجحي كذلك لازاله
المنافسه هناك همم 14 مرحله من خلالها
طبعا الكثير يعني يعني
يحسب انه هناك همم طريق مفتوحه لا هناك
طريق مغلقه يبحث عنها السائق من خلال
المنعطفات المنحنيات الصعود حتى يصل للزمن
الذي من خلاله يوصل يعني يسجل الرقم فلا
زالت الان الترتيبات والمنافسه قائمه حتى
وصول لاخر جوله وهي المرحله الرابعه عشر
شكرا جزيلا محمد شكرا جزيلا لك